this is one of those examples where
bigger is better
gods are themselves actually 350 foot so
if you need a massive screen to do it
justice watching it just now on the IMAX
screen it was definitely the biggest
he's ever foul none of us have ever
faced a situation quite like this one
before you don't think about these
things when you're making the film so if
you're looking through a little
viewfinder everything's all very small
and suddenly your liquor stand go I'm
like oh my god my god it's so much to
look at even just like normal shots have
this kind of captivating quality about
you watch you're on your monitor when
you're filming and you go Isis cool and
then you watch it project it you know
others it's cool
and then you go watching IMAX you like
okay okay you go to stop with all this
now because I don't know how you're
gonna bear this one I want the audience
to feel connection to Godzilla whether a
good or a bad one you want to kind of
feel like there's a soul in there
you're hoping to do when you sit there
in the audience is you kind of get
hypnotized and in trance and you enter
the dreams
that's what films are really dreams
you've never had 16 and I'm just
thinking one day I'm gonna make a film
in that format great thing about today
is that that the format's just grown I
actually never thought I'd get it to say
like you can see a film that I've done
in IMAX pretty incredible who's gonna
send us back to the Stone Age such an
encapsulated immersive way to watch a
movie